I'm joined on the line by Connor Gillies
our Scotland correspondent Connor what
more can you tell us this is a huge
breaking news development in the last
few seconds uh the former first minister
of Scotland the woman who was at the
very heart of Scotland's government for
more than 3 000 days
uh is now uh a police suspect is now
being questioned by police statement
released by police Scotland in the last
few minutes a 52 year old woman has
today been arrested as a suspect in
connection with the ongoing
investigation into the funding and
finances of the Scottish national party
uh detectives confirming that she is in
custody she has been questioned as we
speak and they say they cannot continue
to comment further clearly because this
is a live police investigation